revenons précisément à la libération de
jean marie villemin à la chambre
d'accusation de dijon a estimé qu'il
existait désormais un éclairage nouveau
la cour ajoute même qu'une détention
déjà longue à modifier en profondeur le
caractère de jean marie villemin
avec isabelle bechler essayons de mieux
comprendre cette lente évolution
jean marie villemin qui sur ces images
quitté hier la prison de saverne a de
toute évidence impressionné les
magistrats de la cour d'appel de dijon
la rigueur avec laquelle il a vécu
trente trois mois de détention a
peut-être déterminer ses juges
mais d'après ses avocats c'est surtout
la longueur de la procédure concernant
la mort de grégory qui a été décisive
le juge simon a ordonné un supplément
d'information dont on ne voit pas le
bout supplément qui devrait ou bien mené
christine villemin
aux assises pour infanticide ou bien
l'innocenter et il n'est guère possible
de traduire jean marie villemin en
assises pour le meurtre de son cousin
avant de savoir qui a effectivement tué
le petit grégory cette libération
pourrait indiquer que les juges de dijon
s'achemine à nouveau vers une
culpabilité de bernard laroche dans leur
intime conviction est donc peut-être
vers un non-lieu pour christine villemin
les magistrats de la cour d'appel n'ont
pas craint de troubler l'ordre public en
libérant jean marie villemin sous
contrôle judiciaire
ils ont écarté les risques de vengeance
et de violence en assignant le couple à
résidence dans l'essonne où un emploi et
un logement l'attendent
christine et jean marie villemin sont
toutes deux absolument interdit de
séjour dans le département des vosges